my philosophy of running a company and
solving a big problem is that we need to
be understanding what they're going
through what's the user experience every
single day
my name is steve nguyen i'm the ceo and
co-founder of dre alliance we are door
dash for shipping containers we have a
network of drivers who drive their own
trucks
to deliver shipping containers on behalf
of large retailers
before starting this company i grew up
as an immigrant to to the united states
with my family my parents actually
started a warehouse
in la so i grew up in a warehouse
helping out the family registering
truckers in and out of the warehouse so
i knew this industry was outdated
after college after starting a few of my
own companies i realized nothing has
changed the same thing is still
happening in this industry so what i did
was i started my own dredge trucking
company first spent two years running
that dispatching my own trucks and then
after two years i realized we're ready
to make a move to start a tech company
in this space and help these drivers
to deliver container more efficiently
i think the key advantage of not having
a traditional technical founder type of
background is that i can relate to these
folks that are working in this field and
this is why i spent two years actually
running a trucking company myself
i then graduated from stanford and
graduated from harvard i didn't know
anyone in tech so it was a lot of
networking and getting to know people
who barely know tech and then finally
getting into some investors who are more
familiar with the space so there's a lot
of things that forces have to go
upstream against but it's just great not
giving up i knew this was a problem i
knew we have the right solution so i
just keep going at it
[Music]